>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: JOINING ME WITH
REACTION TO TONIGHT'S BREAKING
NEWS THAT THE DOJ INSPECTOR
GENERAL WILL INVESTIGATE
POTENTIAL FISA ABUSES BY DOJ AND
THE FBI IS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE.
HE'S BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT WHILE
HIS COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN LAZY.
DEVIN NUNES ISUOUS.
I AM REACHING A POINT OF
FRUSTRATION.
THE 3,000 PAGE DUMP THAT YOU HAD
TO SUBPOENA.
THERE ARE 1.2 MILLION DOLTS.
-- DOCUMENTS.
AS WE JUST HEARD FROM
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFIS.
HE ASKED FOR THESE DOCUMENTS IN
2016.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE THAT ROB
ROSENSTEIN FEELS HE HAS THE
RIGHT TO WITHHOLD NOT ONLY FROM
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BUT
CONGRESS, PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
YOUR JOB IS OVERSIGHT.
WE HAVE CHECK BALANCES AND THE
LAST TIME I CHECKED THE
CONSTITUTION, SIR.
>> THE MORE THEY DIG, THE WORSE
IT GETS FOR THEM, SEAN.
WE'LL HAVE TO KEEP WORKING.
WE HAVE TO KEEP BREAKING THROUGH
THIS.
EVENTUALLY WE WILL GET ALL OF
THE THESE DOCUMENTS.
LET ME WALK BACK A LITTLE BIT OF
THE HISTORY WE HAVE WITH
MR. STRZOK AND MISS PAGE.
IN OCTOBER I ASKED WHAT
HAPPENED.
I DIDN'T GET ANY INFORMATION
BETWEEN STRZOK AND PAGE.
WE ASKED IS THERE ANYTHING WE
NEED TO SEE?
FINALLY WE SEE A LEAK TO THE
WASHINGTON POSTS OF TEXT
MESSAGES.
WE INFORMED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WE WERE LOOKING AT THEM
FOR FISAA AND OTHER MATTERS.
THEY PRODUCED SOME OF THE TEXT
MESSAGES.
THEY SAID THAT'S ALL WE NEEDED.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO THE
CONVERSATION BETWEEN STRZOK AND
PAGE TALKING ABOUT THE FISA
COURT JUDGE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS
INTERESTED IN.
NOW THE TEXT MESSAGES YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT, I HAVE NOT SEEN
THEM.
NOW THAT YOU HAVE THEM, WE WILL
HAVE TO TRY TO LOOK THROUGH ALL
OF THIS TO PIECE TOGETHER WHAT
IS APPEARS --
>> Sean: DO YOU AGREE WITH WHAT
SARAH AND I BELIEVE?
>> I TALKED TO A FEW MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TODAY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO DON'T
FOLLOW THIS CLOSELY.
NOT ON THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE BUT FOLLOW IT BY THE
NEWS.
THEY WERE SHOCKED AND USED
EXPLETIVES.
THEY COULD NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE WAS BRIEFED BY
THE FBI ON AN INVESTIGATION INTO
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY COULD NOT BELIEVE IT.
I THINK THAT'S THE REACTION YOU
ARE GEL FROM MOST PUBLICS OF
CONGRESS THAT CARE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE, AT LEAST THE REPUBLICANS
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IT CONTINUES TO STINK.
>> Sean: OBVIOUSLY OBAMA KNEW.
OBVIOUSLY USE RICE KNEW AND
JAMES COMEY INFORMED.
THIS IS A STICKY POINT.
JANUARY OF 2017 PRESIDENT-ELECT
TRUMP WAS TOLD BY JAMES COMEY
THE DOSSIER IS SALACIOUS AND
UNVERIFIED.
THREE MONTHS EARLIER HE IS USING
IT AND THE FBI IS USING IT AS
THE BULK OF AN APPLICATION FOR A
FISAAR WARRANT AGAINST THE
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE OF DONALD
TRUMP IN THE LEAD UP TO A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO SPY ON THE
EMAILS OF AN OPPOSITION PARTY
CANDIDATE.
THIS IS NOT A GAME.
THIS IS THE BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER SCANDAL WE HAVE HAD IN
HISTORY.
YOU GET THESE RIDICULOUS PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT MAKING INSANE
WATERGATE ANALOGY
WATERGATE ANALOGIE
WATERGATE ANALOGIES.
THIS IS ABOUT THE POWERFUL TOOLS
OF INTELLIGENCE AND THE FBI AND
DOJ EXXON
DOJ EXXO
DOJ EXON
DOJ EXONER
DOJ EXONERAT
DOJ EXONERATE
DOJ EXONERAIN
DOJ EXONERAING
DOJ EXONERAING A
DOJ EXONERAING A C
DOJ EXONERAING A CAN
DOJ EXONERAING A CANDI
DOJ EXONERAING A CANDIDA
DOJ EXONERAING A CANDIDATE
DOJ EXONERAING A CANDIDATE F
DOJ EXONERAING A CANDIDATE FRO
DOJ EXONERAING A CANDIDATE FROM
CLAIMS.
WHO DO WE NEED TO GET THE WHEELS
OF JUSTICE TURNING HERE?
I AM FED UP.
MY AUDIENCE IS FED UP.
>> YES.
THERE ARE A LOT OF IRONY IN
THAT.
THE LEFT HAS CONTINUED TO SAY
THIS IS WATERGATE AND TRUMP WILL
BE IMPEACHED.
NOW THIS BOOMERANGED ON THEM.
HALF OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THE DEMOCRATS APPEAR LIKE
THEY WEAPONIZED THE INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES BY USING THE FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE SURVEILLANCE
APPARATUS IN THIS COUNTRY TO
TARGET THE OPPOSITION CAMPAIGN
IS TOTALLY UNACCEPTABLE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
PEOPLE ARE LEARNING THE TRUTH.
I AM HAPPY BOB SUBPOENA THESE
1.2 MILLION DOCUMENTS.
WE NEED THOSE DOCUMENTS LIKE
YESTERDAY WE NEEDED THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
NOW THE DIFFERENCE WHERE WE WERE
FROM A FEW MONTHS AGO BECAUSE OF
THE OBSTRUCTION AND THE COVER-UP
THE PRESSURE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE PUTTING ON CONGRESS, ASKING
WHY CAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE STONE WALL CONGRESS, I
BELIEVE BOB'S SUBPOENA WILL BE
ENFORCED.
I THINK WE WILL GET ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTS.
IF WE DON'T, WE SHOULD MOVE
QUICKLY TO CONTEMPT AND MOVE TO
IMPEACHMENT.
ONE MISTAKE WE MADE, WE NEVER
ONE MISTAKE WE MADE, WE NEVER IM
IMPEACHMENT.
ONE MISTAKE WE MADE, WE NEVER  M
IMPEACHED THEM.
THEY GOT AWAY WITH IT.
>> Sean: IF I WAS JAMES COMEY,
ROB ROSENSTEIN, STRZOK AND PAGE,
I WOULD BE VERY WORRIED TONIGHT
BASED ON THE POSSIBILITY THAT
ALL OF THIS IS COMING OUT.
IF WE HAD AN HONEST INSPECTOR
GENERAL, I AM THINKING SOME
MIGHT BE IN LEGAL JEOPARDY IN A
BIG WAY.
>> YES.
AT THIS TIME ME TELL YOU ABOUT
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
HERE'S WHAT I BELIEVE.
THEY HAVE A JOB TO DO.
I BELIEVE THAT IN HOROWITZ IS AN
HONORABLE MAN AND WILL DO HIS
JOB.
REMEMBER, THERE IS A LOT OF
PRESSURES THAT COME WITH THAT.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HIS BOSS
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THIS IS NOT A SIMPLE MOVE FOR
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO MAKE TO
GO AFTER THE TOP PEOPLE IN THE
FBI.
THIS IS I DIDN'T THINK -- I AM
GLAD MR. HOROWITZ WILL CONTINUE
TO LOOK INTO IT.
I ALSO HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS NO
ONE ELSE IS LOOKING INTO THIS.
HOW CAN YOU HAVE MR. COMEY
TESTIFY TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL.
HE WON'T SIT FOR AN INTERVIEW.
>> Sean: SO NEED A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
YOU MADE A CONCLUSION.
AFTER 14 MONTHS NO EVIDENCE OF
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN NOR COLLUSION
OR ANY EVIDENCE OF FINANCIAL
IMPROPRETTYY WITH THE TRUMP